glaube die Frage mal weiter nach
Washington zu Kerstin klein wissen Sie
denn eventuell mittlerweile schon mehr
über die Reise über die Mission von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
naja was wir wissen ist dass die beiden
sich hier im Weißen Haus um 20 Uhr
deutscher Zeit treffen werden etwa eine
gute Stunde ist für dieses Gespräch
angesetzt und was eben beide Seiten
betonen sie sagen es ist ein
Arbeitstreffen es soll eins zu eins
hinter verschlossenen Türen vertraulich
miteinander gesprochen werden vor allen
Dingen eben über die Ukraine aber auch
über China und der sie haben es gesagt
der Besuch findet statt ohne eine
gemeinsame Pressekonferenz im Anschluss
das hat ja durchaus Irritation und
Nachfahren geführt aber das tun eben
beide Seiten damit ab dass sie sagen es
ist ein Arbeitstreffen die beiden wollen
jede Minute die sie gemeinsam haben eben
nutzen um diese Themen auch zu
besprechen ja es dürfte wahrscheinlich
auch um den Swiss geben den es am Ende
gab mit den Leopard Panzern mit den
Abrams oder z.B dass die Bundeswehr das
2% Ziel immer noch nicht erreicht hat
mit der Aufrüstung
ja das hat hier im Vorfeld für
Verstimmung gesorgt vor allen Dingen so
scheint es mir in Deutschland ich glaube
aber dass das kein großes Thema mehr
hier sein wird es wird vielmehr darum
gehen zu gucken wie man diese große
Unterstützung für die Ukraine die man im
ersten Jahr des Krieges hinbekommen hat
wie man das eben jetzt auch auf Dauer
sichert auch über diesen Jahrestag
hinaus sicherstellt auch dem
entgegenwirkt dass sowohl in Deutschland
als auch in den USA die Fragezeichen
lauter werden wie viel wie groß mit
Unterstützung sein wie viel darf das
kosten das sind Fragen die hier im
Kongress durchaus auftauchen darum wird
es gehen und auch ganz konkret um Fragen
wie zum Beispiel wie kriegt man es hin
Munition und Nachschub für die bereits
zugesagten Waffensysteme sicherzustellen
dass es was woran die beiden sich ja
hier arbeiten ja und wahrscheinlich
werden die beiden bekämpft jetzt reden
könnte ich mir denken da gab es ja heute
die Äußerung des ukrainischen
Verteidigungsminister hat gesagt das
wird alle wird alles nur noch eine Frage
der Zeit sein früher oder später werden
wir die sicherlich bekommen das ist so
wie bei den Leos also bei den bei den
Leopard Panzern
ja das ist schwer zu sagen also
offiziell sagen sowohl die USA als auch
Deutschland das Kampfjets kein Thema
sind das ist jetzt erstmal ganz konkret
umso Dinge geht wie Munition wie
Nachschub für die bereits zugesagten
Waffensysteme das ist das wo es jetzt in
den nächsten Monaten darauf ankommt da
sagte ein Sprecher hier im Weißen Haus
da wird jetzt keine gemeinsamen
Beschlüsse geben aber die USA die werden
heute noch mal einseitig von sich aus
weitere zusätzliche militärhilfezusagen
eben in Form von Munition und Nachschub
das ist das worauf die USA hier setzen
von Kampfjet ist jetzt zumindest
offiziell keine Rede was die beiden
hinter verschlossenen Türen besprechen
ist dann noch mal eine andere Frage ist
klar kommen wir noch mal ganz kurz zu
China sie hatten das ja schon
angesprochen US-Präsident beiden hat ja
gestern gesagt er will nachgucken wen er
da zum Schulterschluss bewegen kann das
ist ja die nächste Herausforderung
ja sowohl die USA als auch Deutschland
warnen ja China seit Tagen davor doch
seinerseits keine Waffen an Russland zu
liefern liefern dort keine Militärhilfe
zu leisten da sagte aber ein Sprecher
hier gestern im Weißen Haus auch noch
mal das bisher aus US-Sicht China sich
doch noch nicht entschieden habe das
eine oder das andere zu tun und darauf
die Frage ob man dann Sanktionen
verhängt wollte er nicht so richtig
antworten weil er sagt wir müssen jetzt
erstmal gucken was China tatsächlich tut
aber das ist natürlich etwas wo die
beiden vertraulich hinter verschlossenen
Türen miteinander drüber sprechen werden
dürften zumal ja Deutschland
wirtschaftlich sehr eng verbunden ist
mit China ja vielleicht erfahren wir ja
heute Abend noch konkretes wie gesagt so
ungefähr gegen 20 Uhr sondern sich Joe
Biden und Olaf Scholz dann treffen
Kerstin klein war dass ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei Ihnen nach Washington
für diese Information
es